I got all the circulating stem cell info from Dr. Ralph Boston.
It's part of his new boss method or something like that.
He says it's pretty clear in the research that circulating stem cells is a significant
issue.
Stem cells is not an alternative issue.
It's well-established.
It makes me wonder since circulated tumor cells are different than cancer stem cells
or so I understand why I'm so advised to do chemo if it doesn't stop or kill stem cells.
Yes, chemo can shrink any small yet not detectable cell families, but also targeting stem
cells can supposedly do the same thing.
Of course, this is an labense perspective.
Yeah, ask that question to your oncologist and probably get pencil slapped or something
like that.
It's true, and then the other negative is going on in your case, you're debunked
your cancer.
There's no evidence of disease in the cancer and they want you to go on a protocol of chemo
therapy.
The flip side of that is chemo therapy is going to diminish your immune response.
The catch-22 with chemo therapy, it's going to really diminish your white blood cell
count, which is going to include your natural killer cells and the lymphocyte line that kill
circulated tumor cells, so it's just bothersome and you mentioned to them while circulated
tumor cells, cancer stem cells are going to be, you know, those are what I need to kill
and chemo therapy doesn't kill them, they just give you a blake stare.
So, unless, you know, again, in a case like that, my prior would be the same as like,
Lord, this does not make any sense to me either.
You have to make sense to me and really give me peace about following the oncologist's
protocol here.
We are called, typically, to use wisdom and what is wisdom, but application of knowledge.
So we have to gain knowledge and you're the first one to look up studies, look up things,
try to learn from as many different people as possible and then you try to apply that
as best as you possibly can and when you try to apply the information from your oncologist,
it just, it doesn't make a lot of sense and I'm with you, a lot of people are with you.
I think the people that just blindly follow what their oncologist tells them to do, hit her
themselves in a lot of different ways, you're just giving it over your personal power to somebody
else and I think it takes a lot of your, your, your bodily autonomy away and your energy
away from killing cancer and I don't think those people have as good outcomes.
So even if you, through all your studies decided, yep, I got to do X amount of rounds of chemotherapy,
then I got to stop.
At least you're making that decision based upon all the knowledge that you have and you're
asking God to now convert that to wisdom, which means how to use that knowledge.
I think that's the right thing to do.
So you're right, I mean, the test is this is circulated to ourselves that are setting
up home to raise a family, those are cancer stem cells, they're in a location now and have
the ability to start replicating rapidly, dividing what cancer is.
The only thing that can keep that at bay is your immune system and when you talk about
these things in this study that have shown to diminish cancer stem cells, it's because
the effect that these things have on your immune system and on a general inflammation.
So yeah, it's interesting that these studies tend to get buried.
I refer to, you know, the studies on neural inflammation where billions and millions and millions
of dollars was poured into neural inflammation, brain inflammation, post-concussive syndrome
when all that HUB Blue was going on about the NFL players and all the lawsuits with NFL players.
Post retirement were having all sorts of neurological issues, you know, increased incidence of Parkinson's
did you hear, Brett?
Farer was just dying, just came out with his diagnosis of Parkinson's.
I knew something was up because he had an interview about six months ago saying he would
never let any of his kids or grandkids play football, and they said, what do you mean play football
like not in the college level?
He said, no, not in the high school level or the grade school level at all because getting
hit at all in the head increases your neural inflammation, he must be going to a functional
neurologist.
It sure enough, he's come out with a diagnosis of Parkinson's from Post-concussive syndrome
from neural inflammation.
Well, I'm bringing that up because all the studies and all the money that was pumped into
that one drug decreases neural inflammation.
What do they find?
The only thing that decreases it?
Curcumin, EGC, Resveratrol, Coursicenter, all the flavonoids, it's the only thing that
helped.
So you want to increase your life and live a long life, even if you weren't dealing with
post-cancer, these things definitely are your best bet.
I think so for a feed, again, would shine, would be more for certain stem cells and cancer
stem cells for the tumors that are more hormonally driven, like genostate, but...